welcome back to New rockstars black
panther wakanda forever gave us shuri as
our new black panther but if I was the
one gambling I have my money on Okoye
did you believe our newest Black Panther
would be Sherry because I I don't think
it was I think a lot of people didn't
this had us thinking who else has been a
black panther and who could be in the
future this is big question the show
that asks and answers the biggest
questions floating around the nerd's
fear in a few of the small ones too my
name is Jessica Clemens and with me
today it's my best friend in the world
Tommy back told hi everyone hello
Jessica it's so good to be here you know
me have I been a panther before probably
not don't think I qualify I don't think
you would be you could be a hyena
oh my gosh well welcome to big question
you guys in the MCU we've seen uh the
Black Panther mantle change a couple of
times we had bashinga uh t'chata
t'challa killmonger and now shuri and
can it stop there absolutely not this
sets us up for this week's big question
who could be the Black Panther in the
future who else could it be and you know
how crazy I am so I went to the comic
books and there are
justifiably over like 13.
um over maybe 15 but some of them don't
count so okay like I said earlier we've
seen bashanga in the first black panther
when they're doing the retelling of them
becoming the Black Panther uh King
t'chaka who dies King t'challa who
unfortunately also passes killmonger who
also passes and now shuri so clearly
people are just getting it once someone
else it's kind of like being uh the king
of Westeros it's not a long job
it's not a long career it is oh no it
isn't and also it isn't for these folks
Unfortunately they kind of went abruptly
yeah but in the comics there were a
bunch of different people some people
that are completely wild some that are
completely offensive uh some that are
just like ridiculous but uh all could
hold a place in MCU storytelling and
maybe we could get into them as prequels
or sequels what have you so here are my
these are my baddies these are my list
of baddies ooh baddies no each and
individually all of them baddies they're
all hot they're all fine as hell they're
all fine as hell we're gonna go over
them one by one and um I'm gonna discuss
with you and you can tell us if it's
realistic for them to come into the MCU
or would we want to see them in their
own story are you ready so we're gonna
start with Earth 616 and you guys this
is the this is the one that people don't
realize people think it always starts
with bashenga people think it starts
with bashanga but actually it starts
with MOSI
you don't need to hold it up because we
have the green screen they'll show it
the panther was the first to discover
the manner of vibrating rock or some
such yes and the first to begin to
unlock its many Secrets never have I
been more impressed by Immortal look at
him he's beautiful he's fine as hell and
also he has an actual like Panther yeah
like he's got kind of like the Beast oh
yeah he oh my gosh I love it jowl hairs
so Mosey comes from a Million BC but we
see him first in Marvel Legacy he was
the first to be aided and favored by
bass to become the first black panther
and in the MCU and a lot in the comics
you think it's bashenga who was the
first black panther but it was Rewritten
kind of like retconned in 2022 when the
comic drops with Mosey saying that he
was the official first black panther uh
so Mosey oversaw the Black Panther tribe
while the Shango oversaw the Kingdom so
they could have also like been like
maybe that doesn't count but when the
vibranium Mound landed in wakanda it
opened a bunch of riffs allowing lot of
different creatures to come through like
The Brood who are just a bunch of
insects that are monsters
um and Mosey defended all the wakandans
but this also attracted Odin and Mosey
joined Odin was a part of the Stone Age
Avengers the Stone Age Avengers which
consists of agamoto Ghost Rider Iron
Fist Moon Knight and Phoenix
Ghost Riders yes was he traveling
through time no he was just there dude I
guess okay so we know that Ghostwriter
kind of got like his mantle from like
hell so it's like someone from hell just
came during the Stone Age maybe he was
riding a sabertooth tiger or a mastodon
I can't oh my God I can't wait to get
into the other ones because it comes out
also Mosey was the first person after
Odin to lift and hold wheeled Millner
yeah so would you how realistic is it
for this character to come into the MCU
and would you want to see their story I
don't know about the MCU because I want
him to to have this story back in time
like the only reason I wanted to be a
Marvel film but I wish Marvel would have
like uh kind of the way DC seems to be
set up now where they're gonna have like
these are Marvel characters but they're
not MCU timeline or just make it another
dimension that takes place one million
years well it could be a pretty cool
yeah I love it a prequel would be great
a explanation of the first black panther
come on first avenger first black
panther give it to us so that okay so
that's what brings me into bashanga and
this is bashanga that we saw in the MCU
because we saw them when
um they're retelling the story of
bashenga and he was the warrior Shaman
who became the first king of wakanda the
first black panther after he was able to
get all the tribes to come together and
the Jabari went into the mountain they
went into the mountains but then but
weirdly the most Cooperative later on
yeah yeah
yeah look at that full circle story so
there's been a lot of rumors online
about them coming into a prequel of
bashanga which would be nice because
then we'd meet other characters but do
we what do you think do we wanna well
see now I'm if you had to choose between
them now I'm torn I have to say most he
still has my heart the shanga is like
you know it's like Doctor Who right they
say whoever the first doctor that you
watch is your favorite doctor this is
most of the time but uh I feel like you
know bashango was my first black panther
but now I'm kind of like
someone evil needs to transport like
seven panthers to like a world and make
them do something together because I
want bashanga and mostly to work in
concert that'd be great I want them to
work together too bad they're different
different times that's what I mean
that's why they have to be transported
oh okay then I'd read into that one okay
for our next one it's neanda or nahanda
settle down settle down settle down
speaking of black panthers she was the
former queen of wakanda and the first
female black panther she was a member of
The Avengers 1000 A.D that consisted of
Ghost Writer he kept coming in Gail the
Atlantean princess with the iron fist so
that could be it to Logan today that
could be it to Logan with the iron fist
give me Gail give in that name wasted
wasted on an amazing character who are
you say your name woman I'm Gail I'm
Gail thank you Miguel I do commercial
real estate I also sell Tupperware at
parties my favorite wine is Pinot grige
oh my now I like Gail even more fun to
party with but after she has that fourth
glass she starts to say stuff that makes
you uncomfortable okay never mind we
don't know where gal was on January 6th
oh that's what you're saying that's what
you're saying
zardos who was aka the Phoenix for she
was an older lady that had the Phoenix
force and they were all led by Thor she
also founded the door milage
okay yes absolutely I don't mean to be I
don't mean to be a repeating uh you know
uh repeating Ronald here but yes MCU
movie Dora milaje origin so the door
milage I think they got a they got a
foreign
book recently came out that has like the
history of the door milage and they kind
of briefly talk about how yeah she was
the one that created and founded it
um and yeah I want a story about her I
want more than a book what's the name of
the midnight Angels what did you think
of the midnight angels
I like the question how many of these
suits do you have and now that okoye's
in I feel like we're gonna get more and
they're different from the dorm milaje
right so they'll be like it's like that
General can still stay with the dorm
Elijah
I love it I love it I'm here for it okay
this bad [ __ ] sorry bleep that
out king Azuri the Black Panther during
World War II this is t'challa's
Grandfather yes so Colonel Fritz a claw
as we know is like Ulysses claw was
working for Adolf Hitler and his plane
crash over wakanda and Azuri nursing
back to health and they became friends
they became friends briefly until uh
claw was like Hey you are the Black
Panther you should be a God to these
people and he was like no we're all even
that's how we work here in wakanda claw
fought him on it and then so much so
that he ended up killing the queen oh
and black panther ripped off his arm and
he retreated back to Germany and then in
1941 Azuri saw the Nazis and Americans
as both like threats because after that
happened I would too
um and then he but he eventually learned
to trust Captain America and Nick Fury
and the Howling Commandos to protect
wakanda from strucker and red school who
was sent to steal the vibranium for the
Nazis clearly they win the wakandans not
the Nazis and afterwards azzuri was like
I hope Captain America is to America as
I am to the wakandans and I was like I
like this but also I don't want it as a
story what do you think I'm going to say
to you
no
correct goodbye I don't mean to be I
just I'm World War II not seed out you
know I think we have to never forget how
awful and evil the Nazis are condemn
them stop putting them on screen uh
except for Hunters season two coming out
January 13th who is your boy uh those
are the only Nazis you can no just
kidding I don't love them either I play
a very affordable person but don't worry
I get what's coming to me anyway back to
this point
uh I also think that isn't there a video
game in development right now that is to
uh to Chaka and Captain America fighting
Commandos I believe that was announced
at d23 I think fact check me on this
editors or don't uh and that is the
World War II Black Panther story I would
love to hear more okay there you go I
think that's good then we get it there
now this one
is very fun oh my God and by very fun
it's just kind of crazy so Kevin Casper
Cole look at this bad boy Whoa yes an
NYPD cop he ruined a fake drug bust and
was put on suspension because he did
that he then stole the Black Panther
suit from his boss he's an ally to the
original Black Panther and no one
thought of it too much because t'challa
had disappeared at this moment so they
were like oh yeah it's just normal black
panther wandering around and fighting
crime right and then they find t'challa
hiding in Brooklyn and demand and he
this little cat demands t'challa let him
partake in the heart-shaped herb and
become the New Black Panther the child
is like okay but you gotta go face the
wakandan leader who's Eric Kilmore who's
killmonger and he couldn't defeat
killmonger but killmonger offered him
the heart-shaped herb that would work
for his non-wakan body and the position
of white tiger and a lot of his
storyline he works alongside Roadie whoa
okay here's where I'm gonna say with
this
not an MCU movie very cool story Marvel
this is the only time I'm ever going to
say this except for the time I said
earlier in the episode I'm on a lot of
cough medicine right now so forgive me
there's some truth and truth and power
Marvel make this a Prestige animated
film not a goofy Iron Man with a with a
bad Robert Downey Jr impersonator he's
fine he does a good job sounding like
Robert Downey Jr he just makes him too
sarcastic only only Robert Downey Jr
should be that sarcastic make a good
serious R-rated animated film about this
story give me the white tiger give me
Roadie give me the heart-shaped herb for
people that are non-wakandan give me
killmonger blood give me some F words
give me make this an animated film let
Jessica and I write it and uh you know
maybe I'll voice like a random white cop
like hey what are you doing here you're
already acting it out and what are you
doing here these inches are everywhere
give me this like um Netflix gave us
Jessica Jones oh do you imagine like a
gritty version of this because it's like
okay I'm like cops I don't really care
to see too much of we got a lot of them
but I love a cop that's just like I'm
the Black Panther yeah I like the I like
to like like it first kind of Stolen
Valor of it like he's like I took the
suit on the Black Panther now and then
it ends up working out that he does
become a hero I think that's really
interesting I agree with you but the
reason I wanted animated is to separate
it and avoid confusion that it's empty
because look at all those Netflix shows
now have either are either being adapted
and turned into Disney Plus shows to
avoid that separation or they're kind of
just forgotten about Iron Fist anyone
when are we talking about the Iron Fist
he's not iron Mist let's put it that way
he's Gail
he's Gail yeah I'm Gail I was a iron
piece I'm addicted to scratch off
lottery tickets I'm Gail get off my lawn
I kissed two girls in college but never
again never again never again a
casserole
marshmallows go on salads oh God I'd
fight her to death okay you guys so
these are the ones that are out of this
world
these are the ones that are out of this
world and when I say they're out of this
world they're not of this timeline
um they're from a different universe or
literally Emperor najodka or else
there you go this was this one right
here okay look at that man look at this
look at this man he looks like Predator
because you see he's not the Predator
look at this man look at this man can't
you see he's getting better I don't know
how much but I know I love you
and that's all we can sing before we get
demonetized oh my God that was a good
one though so this was Eric killmonger
same name but completely different
person different different person that
we've seen this killmonger wasn't from
Earth and Another Universe this black
panther Ruled The Intergalactic Empire
of wakanda wow so a space black panther
sort of space warlord he bonded with a
symbiote over their Mutual hatred of the
wakandan emperor and then killed him
becoming the new real the new ruler he
was still a complete bad person
yeah but also like a space black panther
do I want a space black panther I think
this is a great comic book I don't think
we need it as a movie look at how fine
he is he looks great and his his teeth
stick out of his skin I do like that I
like the way he looks I just I'm a
little distrustful of the symbias okay
well then you're not gonna I would say
you're not gonna like this one
this is cozy I think nagosi or gozie
um she was a young paralyzed Nigerian
girl she got paralyzed in a bus accident
she was a runner got paralyzed in a bus
accident
um who merged with the Venom symbiote
right as king t'challa is getting killed
by Rhino oh yeah so she was like
watching a grasshopper and then she was
following it because she collects
insects and when she got out all she saw
was Rhino beating the crap out of
t'challa rhino that's got to be his
greatest accomplishment
that's the there's a lot of stuff about
this comic that I didn't like but that
was the one that was a that was the top
three oh my God that I was like huh
Rhino beats t'challa okay either way so
he beats t'challa yeah and he's killed
by Rhino the will continents convince
her oh she so she gets the Symbiote
because Rhino was had like a cylinder
glass or a canister and dropped it and
symbiote was in it and she was like come
on we need to go save t'challa symbiote
was like rad let's do it baby and
connected to her and became this okay
yeah I'm on board with this and then she
fought and uh beat Rhino and then the
wakandans convinced her to come to
wakanda then gave her the heart-shaped
herb and she became the next Black
Panther with the Symbiote I mean this is
a movie oh this is a movie this is a
movie this is a Sony movie we may have
to switch some things around but this is
a movie this is a movie this is a movie
could you repeat that oh my gosh there's
two more female Heroes we need more
female badass Heroes that aren't just
assisting the men uh this is a female
hero who will f up anybody so she was
also allowed she was able to like fly
she looks awesome I prefer this Venom
then this one to that one I do okay this
one
look at this one right here I stopped
scrolling this is Captain America no
no
next
wait hear me out hear me out and I need
you to hear me out and I need you to
hear me out I get why you did that I
completely understand so and Captain
America and ultimate Captain America
annual Captain America was mentoring and
training t'challa to be on the ultimates
so in this old in this universe though
his older brother t'challas was a Baku
and he challenged him for the throne and
in order to challenge their uh what they
had to do was they had to hunt down on
actual black panther but the panther
tore out t'challa's throat and the
wakanda medical resources couldn't save
him so they had to ask for the U.S for
help and they used Weapon X on him oh
they use Weapon X on him and he was so
messed up that he like always kept his
like he was kind of like um from the
boys
um that never shows his face oh wow
black and white in the black noir he's
kind of like black noir and so they use
weapon x and zachala had retractable
medical medical retractable metal claws
like Wolverine which we'll get into that
later Nick Fury refused to send joshala
back home to wakanda because he assumed
his father was liable for his throat
injury and so when Captain America met
t'challa they basically had this like
conversation they were able to
communicate to each other and Captain
America found out that t'challa just
wanted to go home and see his father and
didn't want to stay here anymore so
Captain America let him go and wore his
suit imposed as the Black Panther
now when I say hear me out I say hear me
out because I'm like okay
who's our new Captain America it's Sam
Wilson it's Sam Wilson who was a black
man who's a black man now if Sam Wilson
did that gotten that suit
game over
so should I go pick up that paper no
okay because that is a horse Captain
America that is a white man that is a
creamy and a black suit that is a
miracle-whipped like Captain America you
took
saw that image and I went mm-hmm
I love the bad taste but do you think we
can make it into a movie yeah I like the
Sam Wilson version I watch that movie
okay perfect so no white Captain America
put it on the suit and Frozen as black
panther yeah the thing is do you imagine
he was like doing and fighting crime
people like yeah and then like a black
boy came up to him was like I can't wait
to be you one day and he was like yeah
ghost Panther
look how badass I should be yeah I'm on
board look how badass this is you guys I
mean riding a panther on fire yeah are
you out of your mind yeah any animal on
fire that is still living in coherent
yeah it is pretty badass yeah so in
Infinity War Gamora folded the universe
in half this is gamora's taking the
place of Thanos she betrayed her entire
team and she was like you know what I'm
going to take these stones for myself
I'm gonna do a little trick right here
so she flips and folds the universe in
half merging a lot of the hero's Souls
with one another during Infinity War
she created a pocket Dimension that was
referred to as the warp world and in
that Dimension we got black panther that
merged with Ghost Writer to make ghost
Panther which okay I know that we're
like okay so what's the behind the
scenes Jessica what's the story behind
it so this character has a pre like has
a story previously that follows him
being banished from wakanda by his
father then working for stuntman Jericho
Simpson t'challa's new name Johnny Blake
days are so Johnny Blaze that his story
basically follows the original Ghost
Writer but it just with t'challa and
he's on a black panther that's a fact I
like it I like the Flames coming out of
the Panther's eyes
I'm in I'm so in and also okay so then
in that same issue if you fold the world
again which she does what would happen
you know two more superheroes would form
with you
whoa and they became ghost Hammer which
is Thor and Iron Man that meant that
meld together merging with ghost Panther
and it became ghost hammer
yeah
I
Will Always Love You
I thought you're gonna start six movies
and a season of television and a season
of Television I her the outfit looks
like a door milage yeah and their skull
is on fire I love it it's
so badass there's nothing as cool as
this and you guys those were the Black
Panthers that could make their way in
the future I mean realistically I hope
we just get like a bashanger Mosey like
prequel it's kind of hard because the
mosey comic came out in like August of
2022. right so it's like oh we could be
some years away but if you guys wanted
to jump start on this freaking I love it
well and let us do write the animated uh
oh yeah Casper Kevin Casper
speak that was incredible
thank you also incredible this weekend
you can come see Jessica and I along
with Eric Voss and the rest of the break
room cast at La Comic Con we'll be
hosting a panel Sunday December 4th at
10 30 a.m the first person to bring me a
cold brew from Starbucks receives a high
five and maybe a hug if I'm not
contagious
you can learn more about La Comic-Con
and purchase tickets at
comic-conla.com come see us it's gonna
be so much fun we're going to be wild
we're going to be fun there's gonna be
Jay's gonna be there he's not gonna be
on the piano but Jay's gonna be there
Erica you never know who's going to show
up and also like listen you ever wanted
to meet us this is your chance okay
because other than that we go back into
hiding we go back into the new rockstars
Vault for 20 years after that all right
also be sure to check out new
rockstarsmerch.com where there's still
time to grab our latest Obsession merch
the forever King inspired by black
panther wakanda forever you can also
check out some new rockstars merch
including the limited edition enamel pin
I have one where in my office support
the channel and check out all of our
awesome merch options over at
newrockstarsmerch.com
Perfect it's time for verses
[Laughter]
you to death boy I believe it this is
the segment where we pick two characters
against each other in a hypothetical
battle to see who if we can determine
who would win and who would lose
this week we're going to see who would
win in a battle between shuri and umbaku
who doesn't acknowledge that he's from
Rochester New York so he's already out
of points you're not from Brooklyn you
went to Brighton High School okay
Winston it's gonna get out it's going to
get out soon how many times you've
brought it up and he's gonna and he's
been responding to people on Twitter
like crazy I love him he's he I first
things first he's one of my favorite
actors I just wanted to acknowledge that
we at some point lived in the same city
at the same time and then one day I want
to give him a high five maybe a hug
maybe I'll bring him a cold brew anyway
let's look at some of the official stats
provided on marvel.com these are based
on comic book versions of the characters
but it should give us a great starting
point for our discussion Marvel provides
a rating from one to seven on six
categories durability energy fighting
skills intelligence Irish dancing and
strength
it's speed and strength let's start with
the stats on in Baku durability he's a
three energy he's a one that's what
happens when you eat all vegetarian diet
no energy wait what fighting skills four
intelligence two come on damn big guys
are not dumb speed three strength four
all right got him nothing his numbers
are bad to be fair in the comics he's
also like eighth man or whatever man ape
yeah
man welcome to the stage Grape Ape so I
think yeah so I just I don't think they
gave him his Deuce yeah they didn't he
just knock on his flowers yet that he
maybe deserves from the movie go to sure
I want to see what the hell they put
let's remember that in the MCU Boku does
not have any powers he's considered Peak
human with his strength Mastery of
combat tactical fighting skills he kept
up pretty well in a fight against the
tele Canal who are of course stronger
than most humans now
let's look at shuri for whatever reason
marvel.com does not provide their
standard stats for sure but given that
she's now ingested the synthetic
heart-shaped herb we can use t'challa
stats as a baseline for some of these
fake baloney
come on give her our own stats for sure
let's just say durability three energy
three
fighting skills too intelligence seven
but it should probably be a nine speed
three
strength three she's only one yeah it's
like the same well I mean honestly her
with heart-shaped herb skills her
strength should be more than in Baku she
can punch things well this is t'challa
so it's the same heart-shaped herb no I
think we gotta go to marvel.com and talk
to them I'm taking my energy off Winston
Duke and on to marvel.com's rankings
there you go now this sure is powered up
with the heart-shaped herb and it has a
vibranium black panther suit complete
with Sonic energy gauntlets how would
she fare in a fight against imbaku
umbaku would win I think it's easily
well okay wait with the heart-shaped
herb wait
well it depends because
I mean he I mean he took on
did he take on killmonger in the first
movie he didn't take on black he didn't
take on t'challa in the first movie no
and he got completely screwed up by
Neymar in the second yeah but that's not
even the hardship that's something right
that's that's a mutant sometimes people
think the first mutant uh all right I
think
shuri with the suit
prob oh where's oh
if Sherry had to challenge for the
throne against imbaku where she would be
powered how we go I think it would rip
her apart yeah if he was
here's the thing is there ethics because
he's like you know I mean he looks
massive in the movie and I'm sure they
cast smaller people around him because I
know he's not like that huge in real
life but he's a big guy yeah if if those
two human beings just at their height
and weight and physical fitness he
doesn't have a lot of body fat on him so
he's not like you know a big fat guy
that's kind of slow and loses stamina
I think unfortunately he kills here
unfortunately that's just not even a
fair fight because also like we saw but
is there morality in this fight wouldn't
Baku do that no absolutely not also
because the one rule that or the one
thing he pledged to t'challa was like I
would take care of you I'd watch over
you so he's definitely not gonna fight
her but if they did have to you know put
up a little Dukes it's like the OJ book
if I did it yeah if I did it he would
win yeah he would win we saw how small
was also in the movie she was a little a
little bean sprout and what's even
crazier is how much smaller Riri is than
shuri she's like a foot shorter she's
very sure well Leticia writes giant
she's like tall but she was very small
in the little outfit she literally she's
a little bird lady all right
so I think we're going in boxing yeah
but I think if with the heart-shaped
herb sure he certainly puts up way more
of a fight and probably eventually just
wears out in Baku would be my thing you
know what the real fight is is me
wrestling in Baku now hear me out
um
cast me as this no it is wrestling
there's just a lot less clothing and a
lot more water all right well if we're
doing that then I would also like to
wrestle Nakia she's a grieving Widow and
uh I think we should buy only by fair I
should go to Haiti and uh wrestle her
okay from The Hive mine
we got some bite-sized questions okay
it's time for these different size
questions you want to do it sure crispy
crispy crispy crispy crispy crispy
crispy crispy I'm Chris crispy oh no oh
no uh crispy crispy on Discord asked
what would happen if a war scroll was
touched by Rogue
as we all know Rogue is a mutant with
the ability to absorb the powers
energies and memories and physical
abilities of other beings whether they
are super powered or not and let's be
honest it doesn't go well for them when
she does that it's not just human
mutants you can absorb power storm she
famously absorbed Captain Marvel's
powers to the point where she retained
the power of flight and super strength I
remember this she's also absorbed the
powers of aliens and even Gods like you
know Loki god of Mischief so what would
happen if rogue's absorption of powers
ever came up against a war scroll what
is a war scrawl I said that like Tucker
Carlson what is a worse girl what's a
war squirrel let's be honest what's
wrong these people are just trying to
express their freedom and their right to
vote uh okay well what is a war scroll
we all know the standard scrolls are the
shape-shifting M effers that are about
to pull secret Invasion on the MCU not
on my watch
in the comics Rogue has absorbed their
abilities of regular skrulls before
causing her to take on the appearance of
a scroll she also had the ability to
recall
the powers of those she had previously
absorbed that's kind of cool and it
happened randomly at first but
eventually Rogue learns to control
things that's the message Rogue will
control it eventually that there are
super Scrolls they're not quite War
Scrolls but we're getting there
super skrulls have the ability to
shape-shift just like a standard scroll
but they can also mimic Powers the first
Super scroll used technological
enhancements to imitate the abilities of
a Fantastic Four but eventually the
Scrolls found a way to actually give the
super skrulls abilities without Tech
enhancements there's a rogue out there
in Multiverse 82182 oh Earth two one
eight two there's a rogue out there in
the Multiverse Earth two one eight two
that permanently absorb the powers of
the super scroll giving her the powers
of those Fantastic Four it's all good
read I'm talking Sue I'm talking Johnny
I'm talking Ben Graham now the actual
question is about war skrulls so
everything I said before is worse forget
about it War Scrolls showed up in the
comics in the 90s and played a big role
in The Secret Invasion storyline through
genetic manipulation the Scrolls created
War Scrolls which are like super soldier
versions of the Scrolls plus they also
have the ability to mimic Powers meow
so
what would happen if Rogue touched a war
scroll based on her abilities and past
actions in the comics she would probably
absorb their strength as well as their
ability to mimic Powers making an OP
Rogue incredibly op no thank you I mean
not my rogue not my road not my rogue no
my road hashtag unless it's Keke Palmer
then I'll allow it oh man yeah it's time
for our box of scraps
oh my gosh you want to ask me yeah I got
you if you had to live inside one of the
movies or Series in phase four of the
MCU for the rest of your life Tommy the
rest of your life starting today till
you die
which one would you choose from phase
four
phase four okay the fourth one I gotta
get real
yes there's a certain piece
to living inside
uh wand division where you just think
your life is a sitcom
and you're completely unaware of what's
going on around you
now that's a prison of its own so I'm
gonna eliminate that
I was gonna say you like don't worry
darling I want to live in new Asgard in
Thor Greg loving Thunder I want to live
in that sweet Newfoundland or wherever
Scandinavian town with chunky sweaters
you know magical beings just running
around maybe I'm magical too I'm as
guardian I'm super strong I take a few
cracks at valkyrishis like I'm not into
you I uh I end up dating one of the uh
the actress who plays thila Melissa and
Melissa McCarthy uh we end up together
and I just prospered a new Asgard making
Wooden Ships gore shows up yeah but then
he dies yeah but he like rips through
that town well I'm not one of the people
he rips through because I'm like Gore
later and he goes word just like George
Bush I avoid Gore at all costs come on
now that's a good joke what about you
where would you live
I would choose out of everything in
phase four and I got to choose the you
chose literally living in a suburb yeah
I'm a basic white [ __ ] you're Gayle get
the hell why do you think I connected
with Dale so much beat out of here like
you beat your meat okay so if I had to
choose a face for it no hey yo I was
gonna say beat eggs phase four this is
hard this is really hard because I'm
trying to think of this phase four
everyone was miserable yeah it was the
it was the perseverance it was love but
yeah grief perseverance it's all pain in
phase four damn I'm trying yeah I'm
trying to think of one that's my new
escort it sounds so good they have local
theater Productions you got like a a
roach man teaching history in the
classroom
you know what I think I might choose
I should choose wakanda forever because
I want to live in wakanda but I'm going
to choose Shang Ching oh cool and I
think it's because at the very end when
she makes she has the whole thing and
all the women that are fighting I'm like
that could be me because I would love to
be a fighter like the black widows but
clearly I don't want to be under a
control yeah you don't want a guy
wearing a ring to be able to be like do
whatever I tell you yeah and rip out my
uterus
all right you guys that was our episode
a big question
um thank you Tommy my pleasure thank you
Tommy for joining me I will join you
whenever wherever we need to be together
I'll be here and you'll be near
falls on me online call me back told on
all platforms perfect
follow me
or Clements
yeah platforms make sure you hit that
notification Bell send us your own big
questions by commenting below or send
them into our Discord Twitter Instagram
wherever you can find us just don't
follow me in public find me though you
can find Tommy don't look for me at the
Trader Joe's in Van Nuys bye
[Music]